much
okay
i'm sure
good yeah oh yeah
yeah sure hi everyone um yeah thanks for
coming up for lunch uh so i just want to
make a couple of quick announcements
before we start with our uh
uh we're gonna have a town hall on
monday at 1pm uh just on the second
floor so here we'll just talk about like
whatever plans will be kind of for the
rest of the semester going forward so
let's come to the second floor at 1pm
and we'll all have um
i'll send this in an email later today
but next week we're gonna have a seminar
on uh tuesday by amy ward and then
wednesday we have like a longer live
workout
okay so that's it for the announcements
um and so i'm very happy to introduce
michael kim who is a postdoc here
currently at berkeley and he's going to
tell us a very exciting um
area on multi-calibration so thank you
and uh take it away
so thanks for the intro um
i am michael kim i'm a
postdoc here at the miller institute um
and i hang out at simon's a bunch so
um i'll be around all semester so please
say hi i'm happy to chat about stuff um
so
yeah so today i'm going to tell you
about some research that i've been
involved in on this topic of
multi-calibration and its role and sort
of how it's impli implicated in thinking
about fair decision making okay
this talk overviews a bunch of research
with a bunch of different people it's
really meant as a tutorial i really
expect no prior knowledge but
for that reason please interrupt me uh
ask me questions um i have way too many
slides and i don't expect to get through
you know
all of them at all so um
yeah interrupt me i'd much rather have
things be clear for everybody to get to
get something out of it than to get
through all of my slides
okay good so let's get started so i
don't need to tell this crowd but
algorithms are everywhere we look these
days right and more and more they're not
just computers for us they're not just
calculators but they're implicated in
consequential decisions
often about people right so they're
driving our cars they're
running sophisticated targeted
advertising platforms they're making
medical decisions for us um
and actually i like all of these
examples because
in each of them historically the human
decision makers have been highly
regulated right so if you want to drive
a car or if you want to practice
medicine in this country you need to go
out and get a license and often this
license takes you a long time to get
um if you want to be an advertiser in
this country well there are
tons of federal laws uh with strong
consequences protecting individuals from
discrimination in advertising say for
housing and jobs things like this so as
we move
um a lot of our decision-making
processes from a human decision maker
who we've historically regulated very
highly to algorithmic processes we need
to start building up a language to be
able to reason about whether these
algorithms are fair or not and whether
they're how we should regulate them how
we should understand whether the
decisions they're making or implying
are fair okay
so that's sort of the high level basis
of this research investigation
i want to start with just a cartoon
example of the type of discrimination or
unfairness
that i'm going to be focused in this
talk
in particular i'm going to focus on an
issue that i call miscalibration and how
it can lead to unfair discrimination
so
we're going to be talking about risk
prediction a concrete example you might
have in mind is predicting the risk of
say kidney failure in a medical context
okay
and so in this cartoon i'm going to plot
on the y-axis the predicted risk score
and look at how this predicted risk
score varies as a function of the true
underlying risk
okay
and so uh to start we're going to
i'm not going to introduce definitions
yet we'll get to that later but
intuitively we say that a predictor is
calibrated if
on average
the predicted risk score tracks the true
underlying risk
okay so indeed we can see in this
cartoon that on average at least it
seems as though as we move
the actual risk
upwards so too does the predicted risk
score move so that that seems pretty
good
but maybe when we look at these
predictions a little bit further upon
further inspection we find some
attribute that we can split up and
partition the population on this
attribute and discover two different
populations this orange
and this blue population
and at least intuitively it seems as
though these predictions are no longer
calibrated to one another
that
a prediction
in the orange population
means something different than it does
in the blue population
okay and this this phenomenon this
phenomenon of miscalibration has been
widely observed in particular it was
very uh strongly demonstrated
for instance in the context of
medical renal failure predictors
um in this paper uh in science a few
years back
showing that that standard medical risk
predictors that are out there
being used in hospitals are
miscalibrated according to or across
groups defined by race
okay so in particular
in this cartoon
the white patients might be represented
in this yellow line
whereas black patients would be
represented in the blue line
what's the consequence of this
miscalibration
well
when medical professionals use a fixed
threshold on the predicted risk score to
determine who qualifies for advanced
care right who is really the sickest
patients
even though they're using a fixed
threshold on the predicted risk in
effect they're using two different group
specific race dependent thresholds on
the true risk
and in order to qualify for advanced
care as a black patient you need to be
considerably sicker than your white
counterpart patients okay so the result
is disparate treatment
on the basis of race
that that for the same
level of sickness
black patients are overlooked in in
these hospitals that are using these
algorithmic predictors compared to their
white counterparts
the question here it seems like an easy
point to fix by shifting isn't that like
would be more difficult if it's certain
type of much higher variance like
uncertainty in the prediction here it
seems like it's just a shift yes in this
cartoon example i'm drawing it as a as
plainly as possible but in fact when you
look at these uh empirical plots of the
wrist curves they were like remarkably
miscalibrated in a very obvious manner
and so sometimes it's as easy as asking
the question are you calibrated across
these attributes we'll talk about some
of the challenges in
uh that simple of an auditing process
great
any other questions about this cartoon
example
[Music]
yeah so so uh i
probably won't define it exactly but you
can imagine that it's just predicting
the probability of an event say
predicting the probability of
renal failure in this case
yeah so so that that's exactly right so
could i generate how do you generate
this
curve in the real world that's that's uh
a pretty sophisticated challenge and why
this was a science paper but but i think
it i think it you know takes a lot of
work but
um
yeah this is a cartoon you can imagine
that there actually is a true risk yeah
i'm confused by the nominee i understand
that you're getting different treatments
uh but why is this called miscalibration
if the two curves seem like a pretty
good description of your data well let's
uh wait wait till i actually define what
calibration is
yep
these are the pro carbs
for that i don't know
i mean i have an actual risk here and i
have a predicted risk score
so i'm saying that the predicted risk
scores mean different things in these
two populations
yep
great so this is uh you know meant as a
cartoon but meant to represent something
that really happens out there and is
sort of an example of a phenomenon that
i think a lot of us are hearing more and
more about where algorithmic predictions
are implicated or facilitating even
unfair decisions that we see and hear
about in the real world
so
what as theoretical computer scientists
should we do about this
well rather than trying to
pick apart and look at every single
example that we see and come up with a
solution for that example we're going to
try to take a more foundational approach
okay where we try to identify general
patterns of unfair behavior that arise
as a consequence of algorithmic
predictions
and try to formalize these
examples into
uh definitions of fairness in the
language of theoretical computer science
math and statistics
okay and really the focus of this work a
huge focus of the work
is trying to make sure that we have the
right definitions
definitions that balance the need for
general purpose solutions as well as an
awareness for the context in which the
notions are going to be deployed
and ideally these definitions will help
us to really clarify what we can and
cannot expect from machine learned
predictions
and really facilitate open debate about
these hairy notions of fairness and
discrimination and how we should make
progress
towards fairer decisions
okay the sort of pie in the sky eventual
goal that i would love to achieve
is some sort of provable certificate of
fairness
that when you're using a predictor in
the wild that you could look and and the
predictor would provide you with some
certificate saying
hey this is a
proof that my predictor satisfies some
notion of fairness in the same way that
your modern browser provides you with
some certificate that everything has
been implemented correctly within on the
basis of cryptography
right so really we're drawing from this
tradition of
abstracting a problem and coming up with
definitions to achieve things like
security privacy and fairness
okay so in this tutorial
i've already alluded to but i'm going to
start by talking about fairness and
prediction tasks
okay and that that will be where we
spend most of our time but then i'm
going to switch gears and talk um about
something that seems unrelated
which is optimal decision making
in the
context and through the lens of loss
minimization
okay
um and then yet further away from this
i'm going to talk about pseudorandomness
i'm going to talk about pseudorandomness
in the context of learning
and
at this moment i expect many of you are
saying like
what what the heck how are all of these
connected in fact we're going to see
that there's a central notion called
multi-calibration that connects all of
these perspectives
that has had uh
you know started in this literature
unfairness and prediction but
can be interpreted and says something
about all of these topics
okay so that that's sort of the highest
level roadmap for the day
and
i'll pause here to catch my breath and
ask if there are any other questions
and then we'll get started on fairness
and prediction
any questions
okay great so i'll give you some
definitions and so first let's just get
our set up straight
we're going to be working in a
supervised learning model
where we think about the inputs x as
representing people or individuals say
you know
x could be a patient's medical features
and their history
and we'll think about trying to predict
an outcome why for the sake of this talk
let's assume that outcomes are binary
so for instance an indicator of whether
this person had renal failure in the
next
week
okay and we're going to be working in
sort of an agnostic pact model
which just means that we assume that
there's some fixed but unknown
distribution over the individual outcome
pairs x y
okay in particular we're making no
assumption about the relationship
between x and y
the mapping from x to y could be
arbitrarily complex
okay hopefully this is standard for many
people in the audience
um
so the guiding principle that that we're
going to work with is to try to imagine
that we're going to try to learn the
individual probabilities of an outcome
why given a patient's information given
the features x and we're going to try to
do this across
the population as a whole
ideally to enable
accurate and fair decisions
to do this we're going to make a few
assumptions
one is statistical one is computational
the statistical assumption is that i'm
going to assume that i have access to
data that is unbiased and representative
unbiased meaning that the outcomes that
i'm observing are actually the outcomes
that i want to uh predict okay so uh
that reliably i can trust that when an
example is one it's giving me positive
signal towards renal failure say and
when i see a zero that it's giving me a
reliable signal that this person is
unlikely to suffer renal failure and
representative meaning that um
i'm seeing
examples
from people across the population as a
whole
that i that i want to learn about this
these different subpopulations i need to
be able to see them in my data
okay and computationally i'm going to
make uh just sort of assume that i have
access to supervised learning primitives
say uh very similar to the types of
assumptions that i would need
to run algorithms like boosting
okay
good
distribution from which the population
is true
so
agnostic here is referring to the fact
that i'm not assuming
anything about the mapping from x to y
so often in in learning in supervised
learning it's a convenient assumption to
say suppose that y is very well
predicted by some simple function
i'm not making that assumption here the
true outcomes could be arbitrarily
complex functions of the input
distribution of the input tax
distribution from which
x is generated you may i i won't need
that assumption i'm just going to assume
that it covers the populations that i
care about
and then you can sample from things and
that i have samples from that
distribution
if you assume like uh linear separators
or something like that
um
that's a good question uh not
necessarily
um
okay i guess it depends on what we mean
if if the problem is say easy to pack
learn then we'll see that this um
this
is a solution to
multi-calibration
so so maybe it does trivialize so really
i want to focus on the agnostic set
where where where this map from x to y
could be very complex
good so let's return to this idea of
miscalibration and calibration and be
more precise about what we're talking
about
okay
i'm going to say that a predictor is
calibrated
if for every value that it spits out
when i condition on the inputs
that i give that value to
its expectation is correct
okay so what what what does that mean
it means look at the
the individuals on which i say you know
there's a 70 chance
um that they're going to have renal
failure
averaged over that subpopulation defined
by my prediction class averaged over
that level set it should be the case
that 70 of the time their outcome is
positive
okay so so it's sort of an unbiasedness
condition but it takes it to the next
level because we're conditioning on the
level sets of my predictor
um
if if uh
you know let people stare at that and
ask a question if they want this is like
a very central
notion to the rest of the talk
it took me a while to think about it the
first time i saw it
but i think it's well captured by the
fact that when my predictor says 70
should actually mean it in the sense
that it's averaged over the population
it's correct
okay
and so we're going to take this to the
next level and define a notion of
fairness a notion of group fairness
that we call calibration across a
protected attribute
okay so
consider partitioning
our input space x the space of
individuals according to some attribute
say
by race or by gender age
you can imagine that there's uh
a number of attributes you might
consider protected partition the
population according to one such
attribute
a predictor is calibrated across this
attribute
if it is calibrated even when i
condition on
membership in the protected or
unprotected group
so so one calibrate that
is just let's say half the population is
one and one is half is zero you just
like put one half always
uh you're you're two slides ahead of me
but yes
absolutely yeah so so this will be a
very weak concept is what you're getting
at
so
why
of a of x
in the condition so you condition only
on the part of the population
because p of a x can be different
um
i'm i'm sorry i'm not sure i understand
could you repeat the question so
actually
why isn't it
the prediction instead of x but over a
weights so so i'm allowing this
predictor
to depend on the individual's features
okay the
the features should be much more
expressive than just this protected
attribute
so the prediction is allowed to depend
on all of those features
the only thing that i'm constraining
though are
are sort of marginal expectations
uh conditioned on the protected
attribute
yeah good so so so calibration is a
strengthening of unbiasedness
right unbiased would say that
just the expectation is equal to the
true expectation
the expectation say of of
p
is equal to the expectation of y
but here i'm i'm i'm no longer taking an
expectation over p
i'm conditioning on the fact that the
the prediction is v
and saying that even amongst this level
set where p is equal to v
it should be unbiased
okay so let me let me talk about this
notion and and hopefully it will become
even clearer as we go so there's some
hope
that if we enforce calibration across
these attributes across a protected
attribute
that
uh it would move us from a situation
where we had this attribute independent
threshold on the predicted risk we ended
up with two different
uh
thresholds on the actual risk
the the dream would be that somehow this
this group calibration this attribute
calibration pushes us towards a
situation where we have
independent threshold on the actual risk
okay but let's let's look a little bit
further into this calibration condition
think about what notions satisfy
calibration
off the bat
it hopefully it's clear that the optimal
predictions the statistically optimal
predictions satisfy calibration
okay so if somehow i could get my hands
on these statistically optimal things
this p st this thing that i'll refer to
as p star of x
is the true expectation conditioned on
the individual's feature like individual
level probabilities then i would be
calibrated this is sort of our goal this
is this is the thing that would be great
if we could get
but
as i said like in this agnostic setting
we're making no assumptions about this
thing this thing could be arbitrarily
complex i don't know how to get that but
at least it satisfies calibration
what else satisfies calibration
well as was mentioned
uh there's a trivial predictor that
satisfies calibration that just spits
out the mean for everyone
okay so for every individual in some
uh
sub population or in you know the
universe i'm gonna spit out just i'm
gonna look at what's the expectation of
the outcome overall
just give
that out as my prediction this mu
so why does that satisfy well
uh consider
this expectation when i condition now on
the predictions equal to mu well this
conditioning no longer does anything
because everyone got that prediction so
that's just equal to the expectation of
y which is equal to mu so calibration
is satisfied
okay
this this is calibrated but
by averaging over the distribution we
we've removed any information in this
prediction right the only information
that this thing contains is about the
population as a whole gives us no
information about the individual
i guess it's still fair
well let's let's think about it
okay so let's think about what the
consequence of using
such a predictor is suppose that
you know i required this calibration
across attributes
but what if in one population i had a
very informative near optimal predictor
and in another population i just gave
out the average prediction
right so i'm going to claim that this
cartoon could be the consequence of
a predictor that is calibrated across a
protected attribute a
by giving out optimal predictions in the
blue population and these trivial
predictions in the orange population
what's the consequence of that again
so despite
being calibrated in a you've captured
none of the variation in the risk right
in actuality in this cartoon i'm saying
there's there's risky patients there's
unrisky patients there's a huge
variation in this orange population and
you're treating them all the same
so when i draw again a fixed threshold
on the predicted risk there's a chance
that i overlook all of the orange
population
right so yet again despite calibration
across this attribute
i'm
observing disparate treatment
just i'm observing that there are high
risk orange patients who are not being
selected
and not being triaged appropriately
under this prediction score
okay so so i would argue that these
predictions are not fair they're not
despite the hope that
uh calibration across an attribute would
promote fairness we're seeing that it's
far insufficient
good so
really
the concern here boils down to the fact
that the prediction quality
across this protected attribute the
prediction quality depends on the
predict on the protected attribute
right so when the quality of predictions
depends on the protected attribute it
can result in disparate treatment in the
downstream decisions
in particular we saw how calibration
across this attribute a could still
ignore
any variation within groups defined by a
for instance the high risk patients
with a certain attribute
okay so the question then is how do we
ensure that prediction
quality
um
is good across the population
particularly within groups that are
considered protected
okay and and this is going to motivate
our idea of multi-calibration
which we think about
uh very computational theoretically so
so
let me let me say what i mean by that
so
the observation that we want to make is
that actually we can draw inspiration
from learning theory
okay learning theory has this idea of
concepts concepts are just functions
that map from inputs and they're boolean
functions
that often
identify interesting subpopulations
okay so what do i mean by that think of
a boolean function that we'll call c
mapping from x to 0 1
and we can define a sub population of
the universe some subset
of
x
that's defined
through the characteristic function that
if c of x is 1 you'll be in this sub
population if c of x is 0 you're not in
that sub population
think about defining
a subpopulation
through some simple computational model
so for instance like a conjunction a
decision tree a half space something
that uh some concept that you could
potentially learn
okay
and the idea will be to not just require
calibration
not just require calibration across a
fixed protected attribute
but instead try to enforce calibration
across subpopulations across a vast
group of subpopulations for instance
try to be calibrated on the group of
black women who live in oakland and wear
glasses not simply on
these attributes marginally
okay and and really the idea is to
enforce this not just on one
intersectional population but across
every subgroup defined by some concept
class c
okay so if we think about this concept
class c as giving us some sort of
computational bound
then really we're asking you to identify
ever or to be calibrated on every
computationally identifiable subject
sorry there's a question back here
at some point
so the question is whether i'm asking
you know if i define enough groups am i
asking to be as accurate as possible for
instance if i took my my concepts to be
uh
uh like delta functions right if i took
them to be identify individuals
absolutely
right and so the hope
then
is to go from um a situation where
the question is sort of
how uh what is feasible
okay
if i if i define my subpopulations as
individuals this is probably not
feasible for a statistical reason
whatever is represented
teachers are themselves
teachers are themselves defining groups
yeah
yeah so but but um
but i want to not just define them by
single features but maybe by
intersections of features or maybe
define groups by linear thresholds of
features
so
let me let me give you a definition
so i'm
going to fix a concept class fix your
favorite concept class decision trees of
depth five
or conjunctions of three literals or
linear threshold functions
with bounded weights
okay
once we have this concept class fixed
i'm going to require you to achieve
calibration for every subgroup
identified by this class
okay formally a predictor p tilde
is c multi-calibrated
if
for every concept in my class
i appear calibrated even when i
condition on membership
uh sort of
when i condition on the fact that this
concept is won
so i'm gonna i'm going to require you to
do this um simultaneously across these
populations across these sub-populations
which might be very non-trivially
intersecting
so i need i need your score function
this p tilde to be a function of x
if x is a member of many many different
sub populations what what function do
you want to output
what prediction given x are you going to
output
that's that is the multi-calibration
question
okay yeah so so
so to to um
another question that's likely going to
be individuals
so so yes p star this statistically
optimal predictor is multi-calibrated
great yes and the question is whether
you can achieve this efficiently
because certainly you cannot achieve
p-star efficiently
sorry there was a question here
i'll uh
that that refers computationally
identifiable refers to the fact that i'm
assuming that this
this concept class this concept
is sort of computationally efficient
it's decision trees it's uh linear
threshold functions it's not
uh probably
you know 100 layer neural networks
[Music]
it's easy to calculate the c function in
some sense it should be an explicit
learnable function
yeah so that great we're we're
we have to talk about how we achieve
this notion but but cert i'll and i
promise i'll get to that and that that
will be an element of
identifiable
um but but for now let's just think
about the definition
is uh does the definition make sense
yeah so so let me let me uh maybe just
push forward i think a lot of these
questions are going to be answered in a
few slides but i i promise i'll pause
again if if there's still confusion
so in fact we're actually going to work
with an approximate notion to address
some of the concerns there's no way we
could actually achieve calibration
on say individuals
uh with perfect calibration right we we
need some sort of approximate notion if
we want any hope of learning this from
data
okay so we actually work with this
approximate notion but sort of for the
sake of this talk you can really think
of you know remember that there is some
approximation but don't worry too much
about exactly how it's formalized
but throughout we'll use this alpha as
the approximation term
okay and so so how does
multi-calibration compare to calibration
across a protected attribute this is
really sort of
i think uh
an important point and i so
somehow obviously
multi-calibration is quantitatively
stronger right we're just throwing in
more groups so obviously you know
in your concept class is probably the
projected attribute like so at least
you're getting calibration across the
protective attribute
but i want to make a point that
multi-calibration is is actually a
qualitatively different notion
qualitatively it's trying to do
something very different than
this calibration that binds only at the
level of protected attribute
really the point is that we want to
require learning within
not just the protected group and not
just the majority group but within any
population that you can identify
okay and so
here's sort of an observation that i put
in sort of it
it's stated very informally but i can
make this statement formal in a number
of different ways
so if the true probabilities vary
across the population
in a way that can be modeled by some
function in your class
that that correlates somehow with some
concept in your class
then a c multi-calibrated predictor has
to model that variation as well okay it
has to pick up on it
so let's go back to our cartoon one more
time
think about what happens with c
multi-calibration
so really the hope is that
c will help you to identify different
subgroups in your population that you
cannot see
i don't think in this uh
projection but
trust me that i've drawn a box that
represents c equals one around these
points and
so if okay so let's think about it
these predictions might be we said that
they were calibrated overall because
maybe they're giving out the expectation
in the entire orange group
but as soon as we split up this orange
group
and then and focus our attention on the
upper half
then the this low average prediction is
no longer calibrated right so it forces
us to split these up and give out higher
predictions to to those individuals
okay and now we might look and say like
look overall
these predictions aren't calibrated
anymore because to be at this point they
were relying on these upper predictions
to average enough so we have to move
those down
and then maybe there's yet another
uh prediction or another concept in our
class the c prime that didn't seem to
have correlation with the function with
the the population originally but now
that we've split it up
uh forces us to make distinctions even
further and refine even further
hopefully pushing us towards
this attribute independent threshold on
the actual risk
okay so that that's the intuition behind
multi-calibration that's really the
intuition behind why it's
uh sort of a
qualitatively different notion than
calibration across a protected attribute
so just to make sure i don't miss an
intuition
here we would think of
like some of the
c's
would be like the high-risk patients
that that's sort of our
our ideal setting is where
the c can identify
say high-risk and low-risk patients not
just overall but even within
subpopulation
and so like
imagine a scenario where you know within
a protected group within a marginalized
group there is a predictor that does
pretty well on that group but because
they've been marginalized because maybe
they are not
represented well in the population
overall the predictor is not chosen
even if that predictor is in our class
now we have to identify them we can't
overlook that variation yeah so isn't
that precisely the setting where in some
sense p is learnable
um so so that's a great question that's
a great question so the uh how learnable
the
p star is um
is
is a great question so so our hope
is that c at very least correlates with
p star
and we'll see that it doesn't need to
correlate so strongly for us to make
really good progress
that if we have a bunch of
c's that all partially correlate with
the output then we're actually doing
pretty well
but but yeah it is it
there is a tension there
a different way to say that is that
we're doing the best we can with given
some computational and statistical
resources
okay good so that's most of what i want
to say about the intuition behind the
fairness properties of multi-calibration
these properties have been studied in a
number of different works including in
terms of the underlying ranking of the
predictions
in terms of error rate guarantees under
post-processing you can even think about
getting calibrated in confidence
intervals
on predictions across groups and
subgroups
so
we can reference these works and go to
them and look at different fairness
properties um but really the outstanding
question that everybody in the room
should be asking is is multi-calibration
feasible like i presented this notion as
this like amazing thing that gets you
everything that you want
but requires you to reason about this
huge number of groups that maybe
identify individuals or require you to
go to the you know
bottom level of the sigma algebra like
what what's going on how do how do we
actually get this thing
um and so the the answer to whether it's
feasible is a resounding yes
okay
so in fact there's a learning algorithm
for learning a c multi-calibrated
predictor
that uses a bounded number of samples
and uses a bounded number of calls to
supervise learning procedure
okay so so first off let's talk about
the sample complexity
the claim is that i only need
basically vc dimension number of samples
from
this distribution that i assumed that i
had access to
so
the bc dimension of c
is bounded by the logarithm of the
cardinality so one way to think about
this is it says that from a polynomial
size sample i can protect and reason
about exponentially many subpopulations
okay
so
um
good that's what i want to say about the
sample complexity
in terms of the learning complexity in
terms of the computational complexity
what we show is that
you only need to make calls to this
thing called a weak agnostic learner
so
in theory this thing is um
pretty hard to implement there are
hardness results for weak agnostic
learning but it is sort of the core
backbone primitive
of
uh
algorithms like boosting
okay it's the core supervised learning
primitive it's in fact easier than erm
so what what i'm saying is that learning
a c multi-calibrated predictor reduces
to the task of machine learning with
respect to this class of c
okay so really
both of these things in terms of the vc
dimension and in terms of reducing to
supervised learning
really suggest that you should think
about c
as a learnable class of functions
no no no so so the
so okay i'll i'll show sort of how we
use it but um a weak agnostic learner
you should think about it as a
correlation problem so i give you a set
of arbitrary labels
or arbitrarily labeled data and you want
to find me does there even exist some c
in your class that correlates even a
little bit with
with the labels
weak is for that so so very much it
comes from like this boosting
i'll show you in a
second is there's some discussion about
accuracy because we're gonna have
multi-calibration and yeah yeah so the
whole the whole second half of the talk
we'll talk about this yeah
so let let me tell you briefly about the
algorithm the algorithm as a as sort of
a
pseudocode fits on you know this half
slot okay so what are we going to do
we're going to initialize the predictor
completely arbitrarily
give me some predictor
and then we're going to re repeat the
following iterative process
the first step these first two lines
um check the multi-calibration
constraints
okay does there exist some c in my class
on which the predictions are
miscalibrated
find me that c
okay if if such a c exists
then update your predictor based on this
violated c and based on the level set
that it was violated on
okay
and just repeat this repeat this over
and over and over again
until
you terminate
okay and terminate when you can't find
any more updates to make
so what does it mean that you can't find
any more updates to make well
if you can't find a c
on which you're miscalibrated then it
means you're calibrated over every c so
termination guarantees that i'm c
multi-calibrated that should be sort of
uh obvious or immediate from this
algorithm the question then is how many
times do i have to run this right how do
i know that this procedure will ever
terminate
what should i think of alpha as a
constant or think of alpha as a small
constant point one percent or yes
like isn't like a lot of i thought
when i read about fairness often it's
like that you don't have enough data
about the group
and here it seems like if cx is done
like
not one enough you will be trivially
satisfying this and like by setting c
that's right that's right so so
you're absolutely right i'm going to
need that these c's
have some density in the distribution as
well
like that that their image has some
density yep
um and that that relates to sort of a
whole issue of how
how we define approximation but you
should think of alpha as a small
constant one percent ten percent
whatever you can afford with your data
really
um okay so but but the point is that
every time we make such an update we can
measure the the progress we make
according to some potential argument and
really it's a standard potential
argument you can't run more than
uh one over alpha squared times okay so
maybe that tells you how to set alpha as
well
um
okay so so the claim is that when this
algorithm terminates i i return a
multi-calibrated predictor
here's where we use the the weak
learning look so in fact at every step
of this iteration
requiring you to to say does there exist
some c in your class
on which you're miscalibrated it turns
out that that i can reduce this search
problem this search over this class c to
a learning problem over this class c
right i can concoct
labels that i can then plug into a
standard supervised learning routine
and and reduce this search problem to
learning task let me just answer the
question about the class that this model
comes from then really this class
of predictors is very similar to that
which you would get out of boosting
right so
i'm building up my predictor p
from additions
from linear combinations plus some
conditioning but
of the underlying
models
from my class c
so the the claim is that with not too
many updates with not too many additions
of this form i'm gonna at the end of the
day build up a circuit that is only one
over alpha
squared copies of some
function from my class c
okay so so it is p
p tilde lives slightly outside of this
class c but only slightly
okay so the the people who are paying
especially close attention to this
learning algorithm might have noticed
this other proposition that in fact
learning a multi-calibrated predictor
actually reduces to the task of auditing
for multi-calibration
right so a lot of work and effort and
interest
in this area of fairness is about the
idea of auditing predictors can i audit
a predictor and tell you whether
it
satisfies your favorite notion of
fairness well
the the point is that the key sub
routine in this hkr algorithm was
whether or not you're multi-calibrated
in if you're not find me a witness
if you can witness the fact
that i'm not multi-calibrated then i can
make progress and i can use that
auditing procedure to update and to make
progress
so really this can be viewed also as a
post-processing procedure then hand me
your favorite predictor that you've
learned using whatever method you like
your most sophisticated methods and then
i'm just going to run
uh you know a small number of iterations
of this multi-calibration algorithm and
spit out an a model that is just a
slight post-processing of your model but
also satisfies multi-calibration
if your model was a linear model then
then the post-process model might not be
that's correct
the post-process model
will
incorporate functions from my concept
class c
it might be a call you know however many
iterations i run there will be that many
copies of some circuit from my class c
that that builds up a larger prediction
function
but um
very importantly this complexity
depends only on c
okay so the number of samples i need
the computational task i need and the
the the size of the circuit that i
output eventually it all depends only on
c
okay it only depends on this complexity
class c has nothing to do with
the complexity of the optimal predictor
right the i'm going to assume that the
the optimal predictor this bay is
optimal could be arbitrarily complex and
yet as long as c has bounded complexity
then i'm okay and i'll get an efficient
multi-calibration
algorithm and predictor
okay so so
um i mentioned briefly but this idea of
auditing comes up a lot in uh
in fairness there's been a lot of
different works now on this idea of
multi-group fairness
in particular i want to highlight this
work of kearns neil
roth and wu which was contemporary with
the work on multi-calibration they were
looking into multi-group variants of
these parity-based notions like
statistical parity and equalized
opportunity
there's also been a number of recent
works
by members of the audience and others
on figuring out how to do this
this learning this multi-group learning
that i've been describing to you
completely as an offline procedure to be
able to do it in the online setting
so
even though my focus today has been on
learning in the offline setting
a lot of people have been working hard
to make it a reality that you can do
this even online
okay i'm going to pause there
happy to go back in slides but are there
any questions at this point before i i
turn the page
yeah so
um
question is about the variance of
the estimator
uh
i use different language to think about
this in sort of the
tcs perspective we often talk about the
sample complexity required to
guarantee validity of our estimates so
certainly
uh in terms of the polynomial factors of
these alphas and such we do worse than
say standard supervised learning but in
terms of the the leading term this vc
dimension
we're doing the same as as sort of
standard learning
okay so there is a price to pay
especially if you care about very small
subpopulations
but sort of morally
we're doing pretty well
and and sort of at the end of the day it
becomes a practical challenge of how do
you get the data that you need to audit
because if you can audit then
then uh we can learn
another question sorry i asked so many
questions but like i'm just coming back
to this like it seems like when you talk
about the rhythm of example of fairness
you can impact the distribution by going
out and getting more data about the
race in this case
so like has that been like here this was
stateless are you given a distribution
right yep yep
it's a great question it's a great
question to say
hey you know it's a separate question i
i made an assumption up front that like
i didn't need to do this but absolutely
this is a big assumption so there's a
great question both technical and
practical of like
i don't have enough data i don't have
representative data how do i test that
my data is not representative and how do
i go out and collect it great question
about fairness between using some
special protected actions like mexican
gender and then
this actually aligns with having better
accuracy so like should i think of
multiplied calibration as
it's just a way to get better accuracy
where but like should i think of like
should i still think of fairness with
respect to like these original groups
like
race and danger or now am i thinking of
oh now we should also be there
it's a great question so so really the
the perspective here is that you're in a
setting where if you had the optimal
true probabilities
that your features are represented
enough that uh the true probabilities
give you a way to make a fair decision
whether that's by using a fixed
threshold or by correcting and using
different thresholds for different
groups but um
but yeah so the the this notion is very
much aligned with accuracy and we're
going to talk about that in the next
chapter okay so i'm going to switch
gears now
and talk to you about optimal decision
making and talk to you about loss
minimization something that seemed to
have nothing to do with
multi-calibration
okay so so loss minimization and
agnostic learning is kind of the central
problem in supervised learning theory
agnostic learning asks you to find a
hypothesis h
with loss competitive with the best in
some class c
okay so here i'm
i'm thinking of the losses maybe
arbitrary loss loss functions here just
map uh decisions or actions predictions
whatever you want to call them and
outcomes to some
non-negative value
okay so here i'm thinking about
hypotheses living in some decision space
or mapping to some decision space that
i'll call t
but you could think about it as the
interval from zero to one you could
think about it as binary or over a fixed
collection of actions
okay so
hopefully loss minimization as a
paradigm is
familiar to many people it's sort of the
central paradigm of of learning
uh supervised learning okay
um note that in the first half of this
talk first two thirds of the talk um
multi-calibration made no reference to
loss minimization right i never talked
about minimizing some loss i just gave
you a bunch of constraints
but intuitively at least we argued that
multi-calibration somehow required
learning across these different
populations defined by c
so a very natural question then is to
ask whether multi-calibration implies
some loss of minimization and if so for
which losses
so
um to answer that question i'm going to
start off by saying it does imply loss
pronunciation for the squared loss
okay so in particular if p tilde is c
alpha multi-calibrated then its squared
error on the outcomes y
is at least as small
or yeah as every uh
squared error
in your class c
okay so how am i going to prove that
fits on this slide if you believe the
next two lines you're going to claim
that multi-calibration actually implies
these two weaker conditions one is
called multi-accuracy one we call degree
two calibration
just gonna have to trust me or do it in
your head that it implies these things
um and then the proof is a one-liner
okay um
so in particular i'm writing out the
squared error for any c in the class
subtracting off the squared error of p
tilde
um
and
again you're going to have to trust me
or verify quickly that i can express
this as the following sum
of the multi-accuracy error here in
green
the degree 2 calibration error in purple
which i'm claiming are both close to
zero plus
the squared distance between c and p
tilde
which has to be non-negative because
it's a squared distance
okay so so what i'm showing is that the
difference between these things has to
be non-negative so uh p tilde has to be
a minimizer in fact
you know there's a stronger statement
that you can make that somehow the
sub-optimality of c
is related to its distance from p tilde
okay so the further you are from p tilde
in squared error the worse predictions
you're giving
okay so that really gives us some sense
that p tilde is learning a lot and doing
well but maybe it's just for the squared
error
um
so
here here's a here's a here's a question
that again might seem unrelated
when we do this agnostic learning when
we do loss minimization a lot of effort
goes into choosing our loss
appropriately right
in particular the optimal hypothesis
that we get at the end of the day very
much depends on the loss that we've
chosen
what about loss independent agnostic
learning what would that mean is there
any way to perform this agnostic
learning without depending so much on
the loss that
you choose up front
um i think when i first heard about this
uh
problem and when i've explained this
problem to most people most people
resoundingly say no like obviously
your optimal hypothesis has to depend on
the loss
pretty intimately
but let's let's consider a setting where
you can get optimal decisions for many
different losses uh
without knowing the loss up front
so suppose
for some outcome i know it's true
generating parameter okay so i'm
thinking of a bernoulli outcome y sub p
that is sampled according to p uh the
bernoulli distribution with parameter p
okay then i claim that for any loss
function that you choose
there is an optimal decision rule
uh
tau sub l
that takes in this probability p
and spits out the the optimal decision
rules right it's just this minimization
over this explicit uh expectation which
you know the distribution of it's just
saying that for for a given loss if you
knew the true
probability gener uh governing the
outcome you could minimize the loss
okay so
um
an immediate corollary of this is that
if i had
the bayes optimal predictions
this p star
these governing probabilities then i
could get an agnostic learner
by composing this optimal decision rule
with p star
so given an individual x i'm going to
run it through
learn the optimal prediction and then
post process accordingly
so for any loss class for any
class of function c
tau sub l composed with p star is an
agnostic line satisfies this guarantee
in fact with that fun zero
this follows just by averaging the fact
on the last page that everybody believed
okay
question then is can we emulate this
behavior efficiently
right p star is we're arguing in this
talk is completely inaccessible
but maybe maybe there's a way
to emulate this behavior
without learning p star
just beating these tests defined by c
so uh
do people believe that it's possible at
this point
yes if i was if i was talking about it
would it be impossible
in fact okay so this this motivates a uh
a definition that these uh researchers
gopalan kalai reingold sharon and vider
studied which is the idea of an omni
predictor okay so an omni predictor is a
single predictor
that suggests optimal decisions for many
different losses simultaneously
okay so in particular we define an uh an
omni predictor
um
it is
for a concept class c
and a class of loss functions now a
collection of loss functions
p tilde is an lc epsilon omni predictor
if
after we post process by tau sub l it is
an omnipre is an agnostic learner it
gives the agnostic learner guarantee
for every loss in our class of loss
functions
okay
um
so it's one prediction rule one
predictor that somehow suggests optimal
decision rules for all of these losses
yeah yeah so this is just i'm using the
exact same post processing that i'm
going to use on pcr the optimal
statistically optimal let me go back
so it's just this
imagine that i knew the true probability
of the outcome
then it it's the rule that chooses the
optimal decision given that probability
so if i i i promise you
that um
that y is sampled from bernoulli 0.7
now given uh the loss that you care
about
post process to choose the best action
post process 0.7
right just choose the best action given
0.7
does that make sense
so it's just you can think about it
going go imagine that
t the the set of decisions is finite
just go through each decision t evaluate
the expected loss
knowing that the distribution is
bernoulli 0.7
and choose the best action that's the
algorithm that that that implements uh
tells about
argument to your uh like squared loss
was
predicted like the probability
okay
um well so in this case for the squared
error the decision space is actually 0
1. so the post-processing so this is a
great example actually tau sub l for l
equals the squared error is just the
identity function
this will be true for proper losses
proper square inputs
um it it's for
i'm thinking about
sort of arbitrary decisions patience but
it could be zero one it could be
discrete it could be interval zero one
okay let me let me uh
push ahead and just
the question is whether efficient omni
predictors exist
and the claim is again a resounding yes
because multi-calibrated predictors
exist
okay so the claim their main theorem is
that if p tilde is c alpha
multi-calibrated
then
it is an lc of alpha omni predictor
where l is the class of lipschitz convex
loss functions
okay so what does this mean it means
that multi-calibration implicitly
guarantees loss minimization for all
convex losses
you have to do this post-processing but
you can treat the predictions that it
spits out as if they were the true
predictions as if they were the true
probabilities governing this outcome
and you get a loss minimizer
okay so i'm going to push ahead sorry
wonky um because i'm running out of time
and i want to talk about the final
chapter which is on some pseudorandom
version of learning
okay
how did these proofs of omniprediction
go
they follow surprisingly a sort of
pseudo-randomness argument okay so
here's the argument
first step
consider the bayes optimal predictor
this p star that we've been talking
about
and prove that that's a nominee
predictor okay prove that p star is an
omni predictor
second
argue that the multi-calibrated
predictor p tilde in some sense fools
this proof
in some sense
that the proof can't distinguish between
if you replace p star with p tilde
okay and so implicitly then
if the proof can't distinguish between p
tilde and p star then p tilde must also
be an omni predictor based on number one
okay so in other words according to
these omni prediction tests
p tilde is somehow indistinguishable
from p star
okay so this this um
feels like a notion of
indistinguishability
um and and in some sense it's motivating
this perspective that p tilde looks like
the optimal p star according to
computational tests
okay so what would that mean
let me let me give you another cartoon
so imagine that you're given an
x uh an in input x a prediction on x
which we'll call p to live x
and some outcome y okay
and so i present this to you and i
promise you that y is drawn from one of
two worlds
okay either
y is drawn from nature
y is drawn from the true underlying
probability distribution on outcomes
this p star of x
the alternative is that y is generated
according to this model
modeled prediction
according to p tilde effects that i let
you see
okay and the question is can you
distinguish between these two cases okay
i promise you that y is coming from
either nature or it's being generated
from the the probability that i've spoon
fed you i've handed it to you
can you distinguish between these two
cases
and
sort of this perspective this
perspective of indistinguishability
motivates a a learning paradigm to try
to learn a model
whose outcomes
cannot be distinguished from nature's
outcomes
yeah so good so there's a few things i
need to tell you first of all i'm not
going to just have you look at each
in uh individual triple i'm going to
actually require this to be you know
allow you to build up a class of
algorithms okay so we'll think about a
distinguisher algorithm now
as taking an input x
a prediction p tilde of x and an outcome
y
and the distinguisher algorithm's job is
to guess
whether
the outcome y
came from y star or came from y tilde
okay so i want you to build up an
algorithm that does this as well as
possible
and in particular it needs to do it
averaged over the distribution on x's
okay so this motivates the definition of
outcome indistinguishability which is a
notion that we introduced with dwark
rheingold rothbum and jonah a few years
back
okay so in this perspective i'm going to
fix a family of distinguisher algorithms
which i'll call a
and i want it to be the case
that my outcomes that my predictions are
indistinguishable
from the outcomes of nature
according to every algorithm in this
class in exactly the manner i described
on the last page
okay so in particular a predictor is p
uh is a epsilon outcome
indistinguishable
if for every little algorithm in our
class
the probability now this is taken over x
and the draw of the outcome
but the the probability that the
algorithm accepts that it returns one
when the outcomes are sampled from y
star
should be basically the same
as when the outcomes are sampled from p
tilde
um i'm not sure how it
um so i'm going to
i don't think it has to do with whether
p tilde has has access to real
randomness or pseudorandomness okay so
i'm i'm going to assume that y star is
generated randomly from the true
distribution
and that y tilde is generated again
truly randomly but according to p tilde
here's a
the distribution is over x as well the
distribution is over x as well yes
okay so i'm i'm uh
i think we started a few minutes late
but i'm i'm wrapping up i promise
um
this is a notion it's a strong notion of
indistinguishability uh in a learning
framework
what's the upshot well our main theorem
in this paper
is giving a characterization of
multi-calibration through the lens of
outcome and distinguishability
in particular a predictor is c alpha
multi-calibrated if and only if
you can translate it into this
particular class of distinguishers that
yields uh and and your predictors also
outcome indistinguishable with respect
to that class of predict uh
distinguishers okay so we show a tight
computational equivalence between this
idea of multi-calibration and this
indistinguishability notion
outcome indistinguishability
so what
it says is that
i think what i take away from this is it
really suggests
a new paradigm for learning
a new paradigm for learning
in settings where you have new concerns
that you care about so
uh everybody think of their favorite
predict
favorite property of a supervised
learning model right maybe this property
has to do with fairness maybe it has to
do with robustness maybe it has to do
with privacy you name your property okay
we'll call it pi
how are we going to learn pi
well i want you to think up some ideal
model maybe it's the bayes optimal maybe
it's not improve that that ideal model
satisfies your property pi
with no concern about su
you know how you would learn this either
statistically or computationally
second is squint at your proof
and squint at it and devise from your
proof
a set of efficient distinguishers
that if you somehow fooled these
distinguishers
your proof would go through
okay so some for those of you who are
familiar maybe this evokes something
like the sum of squares proof system for
you right squint at your proof and make
sure that if you fold these
distinguishers then you would the proof
would go through
and then once you have this class a
just learn an a outcome
indistinguishable predictor
and you can do that because
we said that outcome
indistinguishability is equivalent to
multi-calibration which we said was
learnable
okay so together just by turning this
crank very mechanically you immediately
get a learner
satisfying property
pipe and again if this proof can't
distinguish p tilde from p star then p
tilde has to satisfy your property
[Music]
okay and so i don't have any time to
talk about it
but one example i think this paradigm
can be used very broadly one example of
this paradigm we recently put it
together
with karen goldwasser kreuter and
reingold
in thinking about
questions of statistical validity under
distributional robustness and shift
let me
see this great
okay i'm finishing
so in this tutorial we talked about
multi-group fairness we talked about
omni prediction
we talked about
finally outcome indistinguishability
throughout
we saw that these notions were connected
through this notion of multi-calibration
okay really i think this is um
these are three points on the triangle
there there can be many more points i
think this is really the start of a sort
of a different paradigm for learning
that is useful for fairness and useful
for robustness and hopefully is useful
for your favorite application too
um
we conceived of this notion
five years ago or so and really then it
it was rooted in this perspective of
multi-group fairness and we've seen that
it's had application far beyond uh
fairness and so
i really think we're at the start and
not the finish so uh with that i'll say
thanks and take any questions
[Applause]
yeah so we'll come back to the question
one i'm not going to think about the
complete application example where for
group fairness multiple calculations
make sense because like what i'm
thinking is that supposedly
and
the probability of this individual in
the group of
being labeled positive is increasing
let's say it's a continuing rate then
not calibrationally so
would just
i
will just tell you that the probability
of selecting someone in the group is
equal to the expectation but it will not
i i think it does not tell you that it
will select the best ones right
or am i missing something i'm not i'm
not sure i completely understand your
question but but we do definitely think
about
how so in this paper with uh cynthia and
paul marin guy and galiana we the first
one in 2019 we we study
how multi-calibration can actually be
characterized in terms of
a ranking solution and really it says
that that you don't
transpose people according to the rank
of their predictions so that if your
goal is ranking or if your goal is
selection rules with a fixed threshold
like there you can make very formal
statements about the fact that you don't
overlook
or you don't select the wrong group
if if it's really a selection about who
has the highest probability
i'm not sure don't understand it for the
discussion because like multi
calibration with respect to some c gives
some guarantees
that's right that's right and there were
multiple questions alluding to this fact
that there are very interesting and
important questions about how your class
c
connects to the underlying distribution
if seed doesn't identify useful
structure in your distribution then your
host
yeah so really it's it's
but the nice thing about it right the
nice thing about it is that i can tune
this c i can think about c as a tunable
parameter that given my data given my
computational power what can i afford
and let's get the most that we can given
our data and our computational power and
then if we if it's still insufficient
let's go out and collect more data
thanks
let me yeah
turn this off